Ari, today, I Trump's former U.S.
attorney
general is calling his claims
of Trump's claims of a witch
hunt ridiculous.
Bill Barr
says the indictment is very damning
and described
the government's case
against Trump as solid
And this idea of presenting Trump
as a victim here,
a victim of a witch hunt is ridiculous.
Yes, he's been a victim in the past.
Yes.
His adversaries have obsessively
pursued him with phony claims.
And I've and I've been at his side
defending against him
when he is a victim.
But this is much different.
He's not a victim here.
He was totally wrong
that he had the right
to have those documents.
Those documents are among
the most sensitive secrets
that the country has.
He
they have to be
in the custody of the archivist.
He had no right to maintain them
and retain them.
And he kept them in a way at Mar a Lago
that anyone who really cares about
national security
would their stomach would churn at it.
So, Caitlin,
bring us more about what
Bill Barr,
the former
attorney general for the former President
Trump, had to say
Well, Fred, this has really been
an extraordinary reaction
from the former attorney general,
Bill Barr,
and really across the legal community
to the level of detail
that is in this indictment
of Donald Trump.
31 counts of individual documents
that Donald Trump
is accused of retaining at Mar a Lago
where he shouldn't have had them,
says the Justice Department,
and that there are photos
of these sorts of documents
kept in a bathroom with a chandelier
in it
in a storage closet
where they're spilled over the floor.
That is the level of detail
that has caused
a really, really widespread reaction
of how serious
this case is as a national security case
and how serious
the risk
was for Donald Trump
to have these boxes of documents
after the presidency.
Here's a little bit
more from Bill Barr on Fox News on Sunday
here.
I think the government acted responsibly.
They gave him every opportunity
to return those documents.
They acted with restraint.
They were very deferential to him
and they were very patient.
They talked to him for almost a year
to try to get those documents
and he jerked them around.
They finally went to a subpoena.
And what did he do?
According to the government,
he lied and obstructed.
That subpoena.
And then they did a search
and they found a lot more documents.
And they're not even
I don't think they're even sure
now whether they have everything.
So they acted in a very patient way.
And where they were met with was,
according to the government and it
and the indictment, very egregious
obstruction
Now, Fred, contrast that with Bill Barr.
Previously when he was attorney general
and even after
he left the Trump
administration
believing that Donald Trump
should not have had a special counsel
previously investigating him and his 2016
campaign, that
that was not an investigation
that the FBI
should have been embarking on
at that time.
A very different tune
from Donald Trump's own attorney general,
someone very, very linked
to his administration.
And so now, Fred,
we're going to be waiting
for the next two days.
About 48 hours
from now is when Trump will be arriving
to the federal courthouse here
to have his arraignment,
his initial appearance to tell the court
he is not guilty to this charges
and these that will be kicking off
quite a process in the federal system
where the court
will be moving
towards a trial to have a jury
look at the evidence
that the Justice Department
has gathered here and decide
if they believe
that the former president
of the United States
is guilty of these crimes
he's charged with Fred.
A highly anticipated,
unprecedented day on Tuesday.
They're scheduled in Miami.
Caitlin Polanco thank you so much.
All right,
Ron Brownstein back with us now.
All right.
Adding to how extraordinary
is to hear from Bill Barr,
the former U.S.
attorney general,
that he brought his sentiments
to Fox News.
I mean, that is quite striking as well.
You know, flip side to that,
you know,
among some of Trump's
allies on Capitol Hill,
This is how they are rallying
around the former president in this way.
Listen,
he says
point blank on tape, as president,
I could have declassified it.
Now I can't.
He says in his own words, it's on tape
as part of this indictment that he did
not declassify the material.
Therefore, it is saying he saying
he could have saying he could have
is not the same as saying he did it.
He said, now I classified this material.
He said that meant
now he can't write
because he's not president now.
But when he was,
which he intended to declassify,
he said that President Trump
will have his day in court,
but espionage charges
are absolutely ridiculous.
Whether you like Trump or not,
he did not commit espionage.
He did not disseminate
link or provide
information to a foreign power
or a news organization
to damage this country.
He is not a spy.
He's overcharge.
Did he do things wrong?
Yes, he may have on the IP.
So, Ron, you know, those comments either
ignore or try to explain away
what's in the indictment.
49 page indictment.
And these are some of Trump's
elected loyalists.
Are they doing this
because they believe their arguments
or they just want to make sure
that they keep
Trump supporters, voters
in their corners?
You know, it's
probably some combination of both.
I mean, you don't hear as many people
trying to defend the underlying comment.
The most common argument from Republicans
has been basically to de-legitimize
the entire investigation
as inherently political
or inherently weaponized,
the same way the reaction
to the indictment in New York, to his
to the civil verdict
against him on a sexual abuse trial.
The basic argument is
that there is a conspiracy
so vast, as Joe McCarthy
might have said,
in kind
of all of these different institutions,
to produce
all of these unfounded allegations
against Donald Trump.
And they are both cementing
and reflecting
the dominant view
inside the Republican coalition.
But as I said, outside
of the Republican coalition,
not surprisingly, Fred,
multiple criminal indictments
is not a way to broaden your support.
I think there's evidence of that
in polling both before
and after this indictment.
But the Republicans
who believe this is a problem either
because it shows behavior
that should not get
into the Oval Office again
or even on a more crass
political grounds,
that it does not suggest
he would be a strong general election
nominee by and large,
they are once again
biting their tongue
and allowing the Trump
defenders to drive the dialog
in red America.
All right.
And then there are some Republicans
who are not biting their tongue,
who are criticizing
the president outright for his handling
of these classified documents.
And this is what they said,
some of them today.
They have to come out and acknowledge
this is different.
This is serious.
Even if even half of this stuff is true.
He's in real trouble
and it is self-inflicted.
And I just see too many of the candidates
trying to walk around it.
We'll see what happens To your point,
you have to be clear and transparent.
You're running against this guy.
He's hoping you by 40 points.
Everybody needs to come out in concert.
So it's not just a Chris
Christie hitting Donald Trump
or this candidate hitting Donald Trump.
It is a party message
that's very, very important
because Donald Trump doesn't
represent the Republican Party.
He doesn't.
He only represents himself.
This is bad for our country,
bad for the presidency.
And it is a legitimate campaign issue.
We do not need to have our commander
in chief of this country
not protecting our nation secrets.
Think about
when you talk about
the equal application of the law.
If these allegations
and probable cause
have been found
against any military person
or any public servant
that wasn't named Donald Trump,
they would have been
indicted a long time ago.
All right. Sununu's not running.
Hutchinson is.
So how effectively does
this give Republican challengers
kind of a restart
on distinguishing themselves?
Well, we're going to have to see
what what they do with it.
As I said,
I mean, there are two different
arguments here
that are both potentially
have an audience
even in a Republican coalition, one.
As Asa Hutchinson said this
and this is not behavior
that that
you would expect in a president.
This is a kind of a reckless attitude
that calls into question
the fitness of somebody
to be president again.
And, in fact, Mike Pence
said last week in his announcement
that Donald Trump
and his attitude toward the Constitution,
what he tried to do after the election
in 20, 20 should not be president again.
But Pence would not go the next step.
And say that he wouldn't support him
if he was the Republican nominee in 2024
which was
which was kind of head spinning.
But he wants the votes potentially.
Yeah. Right.
I mean
and then there's
you know, there's
even a more kind of utilitarian argument
for Republicans that not surprisingly,
if you look at polling voters
outside of the Republican coalition
are in fact disturbed
by the kind of behavior
that we have seen from Trump
since Election Day
in November
20, 20 from January six
to these various indictments
against them to the civil judgment
against them on sexual abuse.
And you can raise the question
of whether he is an effective nominee.
But Republicans
feel enormous pressure
to fall into line behind.
They are stitching their own straitjacket
by by refusing to even discuss
the underlying
potential validity of the facts
laid out in the indictment
and preemptively dismissing it
as a weaponized
kind of a political witch hunt.
It's a very difficult governor.
Sununu is right about one point.
Donald Trump is way ahead in this race.
Most Republican voters
believe he won in 2020
most Republican voters
were satisfied with his presidency.
You're going to have to give them
a good reason to move beyond him.
He is providing
pretty plenty of ammunition
to those other candidates.
The question is whether they have kind of
the nerve to use it.